America is the freest most Freedom full
country in the entire world despite what
some Hack YouTube lawyer says and for
those traveling internationally for the
first time you may be surprised to learn
that many American rights freedoms and
values are not universally held abroad
in fact one country's Liberty can be
another country's crime but in fact we
Americans are so constantly surrounded
by so much Freedom that we often just
take it for granted like David Foster
Wallace's metaphor one fish asks another
how's the water today and the other fish
shoots him with an AR-15 and if you've
spent your entire life in the land of
the free and Home of the Brave it can be
easy to overlook the other countries
that are in fact not America there are
tons of Rights and activities that are
perfectly legal in the United States but
could land you in some hot water if you
tried it in another country like the
mullet hairstyle for example the mullet
that iconic hairstyle of 1980s actors
rock stars and athletes really has no
business continuing to exist in the 21st
century and yet inexplicably it still
does but this is America damn it where
you don't have to fight for your right
to party in the back and business in the
front but if you want to cosplay as Joe
Dirt or compete in the USA mullet
championships
yes that is a very real thing that
people do then it is your right as an
American to look like an idiot in fact
that might be the most fundamental
American right that there is but for
certain freedom-hating countries trying
to save you from yourselves the mullet
and other crimes of fashion constitute a
criminal offense for example in 2010
Iran's Ministry of culture officially
said goodbye to mullets Banning the
hairstyle for being unislamic in an
effort to rid the country of so-called
decadent Western haircuts Iran launched
a Crackdown on mullet's elaborate spikes
and long hair because nothing says
decadence like the mullet now in years
leading up to the band police have
actually raided barbershops that offer
these disfavored hairstyles after the
band violators have been subject to
fines and impromptu haircuts by the
police for violating these standards
government officials have even gone to
hairdressing trade shows to outline what
haircuts are legal also in 2021 North
Korea launched his own war against
mullets and other foreign Styles in an
effort to crack down on so-called
non-socialist hairdos the Rogue
communist country out log moats and
spiky dyed hair while also enlisting the
state-run Socialist patriotic Youth
League to act as literal Fashion Police
against the banned Cuts nose and lip
piercings skinny jeans and branded
t-shirts were also outlawed and though
this is hardly the worst human rights
violation of this repressive regime
seems like Kim Jong-un is in no place to
prosecute anyone for ridiculous haircuts
and it's not just hairstyles that don't
make the cut pun 100 intended in the
nation of Tajikistan the secular
government has waged a war on beards in
an effort to crack down on what it sees
as the influence of Islamic radicalism
the country only clean-shaven men can
get passports and beards are often
forcibly shaved off by police officers
so if you're a her sweet hipster looking
to open up that barber shop just for
that ironic beard and mustache you'll
have to look outside of Tajikistan but
obviously you've already set the shop in
Williamsburg anyway but just because
it's legal to get a really terrible
haircut in the United States doesn't
mean that you won't be be subject to a
good spanking unless you're outside of
the United States because when it comes
to raising children there is a fierce
debate as to whether parents should
spank their kids some parents live by
the adage to use your words not your
hands while other parents particularly
those influenced by older Generations
live by the biblically inspired aphorism
spare the rod spoil the child but as a
strictly legal matter here in the grand
old us of a the right to spank your kids
shall not be in French in fact the use
of corporal punishment on one's own
children defined as banking paddling or
other forms of physical punishment to
correct misbehavior is protected by law
in all 50 states plus the District of
Columbia now for those of us whose
parents spanked us as kids that probably
doesn't surprise you what might surprise
you in most of the United States is that
it remains perfectly legal for teachers
to paddle children in school and not
just in Springfield Elementary School
[Music]
looking at the window
that's a Badland in fact in 1977 the
Supreme Court upheld the
constitutionality of school spankings in
Ingram versus Wright the Court ruled 5-4
that paddling children in public schools
did not violate the 8th Amendments ban
on cruel and unusual punishment as a
result the Supreme Court left it up to
the states to decide whether to allow
spanking in educational settings or to
ban it oh yeah
and today 19 U.S states still allow
Public School Personnel to use corporal
punishment from preschool to the 12th
grade and for private schools corporal
punishment remains legal in every U.S
state except New Jersey and Iowa but
outside the United States there has been
a clear Trend not merely to dissuade
parents from spanking children but to
actually make the practice illegal in
1979 Sweden became the first country to
explicitly ban spanking this was wildly
controversial at the time sparking
contentious debate about parental rights
versus State responsibilities and some
Swedish headlines at the time included
the quote swedes have gone mad and the
government takes charge of parenting in
Sweden but over the past four decades
the trend against spanking has been on
the rise all over the world in fact
according to the American spanking
Institute in conjunction with mothers
for hand smacking I'm just kidding I've
made both of those just up you've got to
stay on your toes no I mean according to
the global initiative to end all
corporal punishment of children a total
of 63 countries have made smacking
children illegal in any setting
including at home and countries on this
list span five continents and in 2022
Wales became the latest country to ban
the practice and the bands are even more
numerous in school settings with
corporal punishment and schools now
outlawed in 135 countries oh you better
believe that Japan
decades after Sweden's ban anti-spanking
Advocates can point to hard data that
suggests that a direct correlation
between spanking bans and better
adjusted children but that being said
the prospect of actually prohibiting
spanking at home remains unlikely in the
United States as many consider such a
ban to be an oppressive intrusion by the
state into parental rights and even in
the 21st century spanking in the U.S has
its share of high-profile Defenders
particularly on the conservative side of
the aisle I got hit with a strap Bam Bam
Bam and I've never been to a shrink in
2014 Fox news commentator Sean Hannity
famously defended parents rights to
spank their children citing his own
upbringing by beating the desk with a
belt to a confused panel I got it like
this yeah yeah and I deserved it I was a
troubled kid now notwithstanding the
views of the obviously well-adjusted
commentator who clearly turned out fine
spanking has seen a notable decline in
the U.S the proportion of parents who
utilize the practice has dropped from 50
in 1993 to only 35 in 2017. but look if
you want your children to turn out like
Sean Hannity then maybe start with some
spankings but that takes us to a topic
that almost everyone agrees on and that
is cannabis
because in a nation that seems
increasingly divided on almost every
single issue one of the few areas of
bipartisan agreement is the Embrace of
legal marijuana now although cannabis
remains illegal under federal law the
feds have allowed states to experiment
with their own loose and restrictions
because well well I'll let John Mulaney
explain that one with weed it was just
something we wanted really badly and we
kept asking them for 40 years like
excuse me
and then suddenly the government became
like cool parents and they're just like
okay here
take a little
we'd rather you do it in the house and
go somewhere else
but that being said Customs and Border
Patrol Works tirelessly to prevent drugs
from entering this country like the time
that they celebrated the introduction of
this massive Hall of drugs from entering
American Shores thank you for your
service but as of 2022 recreational
marijuana is currently legal in 18
states DC and Guam 31 States plus DC
have decriminalized low-level offenses
and whopping 37 states allow it for
medical use with public support for full
legalization standing at a record 68
percent Americans certainly have come a
long way since the days of Reefer
Madness innocently they dance
innocent of a new and deadly Menace
lurking behind closed doors
marijuana the burning weed with its
roots in hell but try to take that wacky
tobacco outside of our borders and you
could find yourself in severe legal
Jeopardy in fact in a handful of
countries possession of cannabis could
have you staring down a hangman's noose
and this disparate legal treatment of
cannabis abroad was recently put on
display following a high-profile
detention in Putin's Russia in February
2022 U.S women's basketball Superstar
Brittany Greiner was arrested after
Customs authorities claimed to have
found a cannabis Vape oil cartridges in
her carry-on bag but given that
greiner's arrest came days before Russia
invaded Ukraine some have speculated
that the Kremlin arrested Miss Greiner
to pressure the U.S and others to not
stand in the way of Putin's Invasion to
that point Russia has been known to
falsify drug charges against critics in
the past so it's certainly not out of
the realm of possibility that the same
happened here I guess she should just
consider herself lucky that she wasn't
Poisoned With a radioactive of substance
but while a few dozen countries have
relaxed restrictions on the plant the
recreational and medical use of cannabis
remains very illegal in the vast
majority of Nations for example in 2021
24 year old British soccer coach Billy
Hood was arrested in the United Arab
Emirates with four bottles of CBD Vape
oil in his car local authorities charged
Mr Hood with drug trafficking and then
sentences him to 25 years in a Dubai
prison Mr Hood's sentence was then
reduced to 10 years on appeal but he
remains incarcerated in 2013 Egypt
executed Charles Raymond Ferndale a 74
year old British citizen for allegedly
smuggling three tons of hashish which
Ferndale insisted until his death that
he had been tricked into doing by Third
parties in 2021 Singapore is sentenced
Omar Jacob to death for bringing at
least two pounds of cannabis into the
country in 2018 and like Ferndale his
lawyers also argued he did not knowing
laboring drugs into the country though
despite America's comparatively looser
pot restrictions America still has over
40 000 people in jail for marijuana
offenses something that absolutely
requires fixing and even with these
disparities at the very least though
toking up the United States will not
result in the death sentence but that's
something that you can change in America
because you have the right to vote but
you also have the right to not vote if
you
well millions of Americans stand up
every election day to have their voices
heard millions of Americans also choose
to sit down stay home and deliberately
not vote at all if I were registered to
vote I'd send these clowns a message by
staying home on Election Day and
dressing up like a clown now it might
seem obvious to say that you have the
right not to participate in American
elections but it might surprise you to
learn that staying home on Election Day
is actually illegal in over two dozen
countries that's right in 27 countries
all eligible citizens are required by
law to register and vote in every single
election though several countries like
Chile Italy and the Dominican Republic
that previously adopted mandatory voting
have since abandoned the practice a
handful of countries with compulsory
voting don't actually enforce any
penalty for failure to vote like
Bulgaria Costa Rica and Mexico but over
a dozen countries enforce a penalty for
failing to vote in elections some
countries penalize non-voters with
outright disenfranchisement in Singapore
a voter that misses an election is
removed from voting roles and must
re-register and submit a valid reason
for non-voting other countries issue
fines and can even result in jail time
Brazil requires all eligible citizens
excluding the illiterate voters age 16
and 17 and those age 70 to vote or be
subject to a fine of less than one
dollar in Australia citizens are legally
required to go to their polling place
but can choose to decline to participate
after signing in however failure to show
up at the polling place at all can
subject Aussies to a fine of 100 digits
probably or the equivalent of 14 to 34
US Dollars and citizens who repeatedly
refuse to pay the small fine can
actually go to jail among countries with
compulsory voting laws there are those
that tie voting directly to your
pocketbook for example in Peru a voter
must have a stamped voting card to
obtain certain services and goods from
some public offices and in Bolivia a
voter is given a card to prove
participation in a citizen who cannot
show proof of voting within three months
after the election will be ineligible to
receive a salary from the bank advocates
for this compulsory system like in the
Democratic participation to civil
responsibilities like taxation the jury
duty and military service and argue that
participating in democracy is a duty
instead of a right others argue that
forcing people to vote compel's higher
voter turnout as Australia rarely Falls
below 90 participation well Brazil's
most recent presidential election was
just below 80 and compare that to the
United States where voter turnout
struggles to crack 50 in a midterm
election and only occasionally breaks 60
in presidential contests however the
idea of forcing people to vote and
punishing them for non-participation is
not a popular concept among nations with
a voluntary suffrage critics see voting
as a Civic right rather than a duty and
contend that forcing someone to vote is
counter to the very idea of Liberty and
free choice and some American legal
Scholars contend that mandatory voting
laws would constitute compelled speech
that violates the First Amendment as the
right to speak necessarily involves the
freedom not to speak so as long as you
live in the United States you can rest
assured of your constitutional right to
say none of the above the only thing not
silly is the power of the people's vote
and I think the people should feels it
to vote for him
none of the above now if you want to see
even more dumb criminals and terrible
lawyers check out my new video too hot
for YouTube but I'm sorry to tell you
it's too hot for YouTube to see that
video you'll have to head over to
today's sponsor nebula and curiosity
stream because on nebula my videos
always come out early with zero ads and
I release exclusive content all the time
like an entire video about legal stories
that are not safe for work and are way
too hot for YouTube as well as exclusive
videos like things people misunderstand
about the Constitution why nfts are bad
for creators and my first full-length
documentary bad law words good and tons
more all exclusive to nebula and even
though this exclusive content is
available only on nebula you can get
nebula for free with curiosity stream
nebula is Creator owned and Creator
operated there's new exclusive content
released multiple times every single day
oh and by the way we've been developing
nebula like crazy nebula now has apps
for iOS Android Apple TV Roku Fire TV
Android TV and it was recently nominated
for its first streamy award my fellow
creators and I really care about nebula
and that's why we're thrilled to be
partnering with curiosity stream because
they're the go-to source for the best
documentaries and long-form educational
content on the internet they even have
an entire section devoted to Unsolved
Mysteries and crime so if you like my
videos you'll love the thousands of
titles on curiosity stream and the best
way to get access to nebula and all the
incredible content is through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal with its current sales price of
less than 15 a year to get full access
for both sites and to be clear that
nebula's subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
access to two great streaming sites with
content that you'll actually watch and
enjoy for less than fifteen dollars a
year but only at the current sales price
and what's more signing up will actually
help countless independent educational
creators Beyond just legal eagle so sign
up now by clicking on this button that's
on screen right now or you can click on
the link that's down in the description
it's a great way to support educational
content and get tons of exclusive
content you'll actually love so click on
the link right now and after that click
on this playlist over here for more
legal eagle so click here or I'll see
you in Court